all right everyone we have a supposed
synopsis leaked for the Black Widow solo
movie now although this isn't official
it does come from a recent production
listing from a subscription-based
publication that deals with this
information so it's a very legitimate
source quick reminder about the giveaway
I'm giving away a copy of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray
special edition poster and some special
memorabilia from our partners at silk
and cotton all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
the synopsis reads at Birth the Black
Widow
aka Natasha Romanov is given to the KGB
which grooms her to become its ultimate
operative when the USSR breaks up the
government tries to kill her as the
action moves to present-day New York
where she is a freelance operative the
standalone film will find Romanov living
in the United States 15 years after the
fall of the Soviet Union so this does
seem to line up with everything that
we've heard about the movie so far so it
is very possible that this is 100%
legitimate this also falls in line with
the heavy speculation that this movie
would be a prequel taking place before
all the events that we've seen in the
MCU so far Marvel has hired Kate
shoreland to direct a movie and Scarlett
Johansson is not only going to be the
star of the movie but she's also going
to be involved as a creative producer as
well which is great news as well for the
movie because nobody knows the MCU Black
Widow as well as Scarlett Johansson does
seeing us how she's played the character
since Iron Man 2
[Music]
also reported as part of the plot is the
y2k virus everyone was freaking out
about this in 1999 and apparently in the
movie we will see a young roughly 16
years old natasha romanoff stop it from
happening preventing another Cold War
this will only be part of the movie
seeing as how we're going to see her
from her youth right up until the years
before Iron Man 2 it's also pretty much
all but confirmed that Hawkeye will be
in the movie this makes perfect sense
because we learn in the first Avengers
movie that she was on shields radar in a
bad way and Hawkeye was actually sent to
kill Black Widow but he makes another
choice and ultimately she ends up
working for shield is this love agent
Romanoff love is for children I owe him
the debt before I worked for shield I
well I made a name for myself I have a
very specific skill set the Winter
Soldier
aka Bucky Barnes is also heavily
speculated to make an appearance along
with Nick Fury and Agent Coulson so
there you have it the first synopsis for
the solo Black Widow movie this is most
likely part of the handful of movies
that will kick off phase 4 of the MCU so
let me know what you think let me know
who you think will see in the movie and
let me know how excited you are for the
solo black widow movie another reminder
about the giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]